this tell me this Aaron you make popular
YouTube videos you've got millions of
hits and you don't know the basics about
instrumental ISM realism constructive
empiricism selection is unconstraint
philosophy so if you're not interested
in philosophy why you talking about
metaphysics by the way here's the thing
if you understood the so challenge
challenge the first was the signs you
see another road this okay all they
needed the correspondence theory of
truth finds oh we're done series when
doctors see the truth is using selection
ISM is wrong exactly exactly
but you believe in scientific it sounds
like you've been inside to be really why
because I would have thought that I
believed in Harris's no no no okay iren
like this get really silly not all right
empiricism scientific realism two
different catalysts no it's two
different categories right
they're both empiricism for you to think
scientific realism saying different to
scientific important to Morris ISM it's
two different things your descriptions
again okay
scientific realism scientific
instrumental ISM what are they okay
scientific realism is we believe in
claims about observables that scientists
make and we believe in claims which are
made of an honorable unobservable
entities structures and processes you
can really say okay so for example who
would be a good
give me the other because I don't like
that okay so when it comes to general
relativity general relativity says time
and space is flexible and it also makes
other sort of claims and you have claims
for example in quantum mechanics about
the Copernican interpretation at this
interpretation and that many Wells want
so a scientific realist would say when
scientists are talking about the
unobservable entities structures and
processes they are talking about actual
things right so that's realism the
second view is scientific in if there
are people who think that the public art
is not real no no I'm talking much
scientific realism and scientific
instrumental ISM okay now tell me
whether you agree with antique
instrumentalism scientific
instrumentalism says this we believe in
claims that scientists make about
observable entities I'm just giving
philosophical definition okay I know you
clearly know so claims about
unobservable entities processes and
structures we have been be agnostic
about them we're not going to say they
are true we're not gonna say they are
false
we're just gonna remain agnostic about
it right now I've given you two
divergent views and there's some views
in the middle right now which ones uses
Barton was instrumental
now if you may the instrumentalism why
your base believe him okay do you
subscribe to it then that basically
means when scientists are speaking about
natural selection being a creative force
for the generation okay I'm not I'm not
eating the topic just give me a second
when scientists are talking about
unobservable entities processes and
structures they are not saying something
which is true they are saying something
which they it might be true or might be
false the agnostic body so if your
scientific instrumentalist that means
Darwinian evolution which you proposed
which you support and bullying take
their weight
I'm serious that basically means you
don't believe it to be true if you're an
instrumentalist so i basically means
this whole this whole time I don't know
aeryn aeryn aeryn aeryn snot Warren it's
not our environment we know what you
just did
well I made a little hole you walked
into it no you just admitted your
scientific instrumentalist if you want
to you just say that you did say that
that means you believe science doesn't
give you truth but give you instrumental
useful theories
oh no but I can show what it's true
don't deny that but okay that means that
you that means that your claims about
science if you truth is false